bienvenue dans paf paf vous le savez
c'est cette émission au débat de
l'actualité avec un sommaire chargé on
parlera des propos de Christian Estrosi
sur la 5e colonne islamique on parlera
peut-être du nouveau nom de l'UMP on en
avait déjà parlé mais visiblement ça
passe moins facilement que de l'espérer
Nicolas Sarkozi peut-être des primaires
qui auront lieu à l'UMP mais qui
n'auront peut-être pas lieu au Parti
socialiste on parlera aussi des bateaux
de migrants qui coulent en Méditerranée
on parlera de l'éducation est-ce que
s'agit du massacre des innocents comme
le dit le journal Mariane ou alors
est-ce que comme le dit Najad Valou
Belkassem personne n'a rien compris à la
réforme des collèges on reviendra sur le
conflit entre les restaurateurs les
hôteliers et booking.com puisqu'il y a
de nouveau dans l'affaire et Jean-Luc
mec nous en parlera on parlera aussi de
football et des mairies tenues par le
Front national celle de mante la ville
notamment qui a supprimé les subventions
au club de football pour parler de tous
ces sujets et de quelques autres encore
Jean-Luc madek bonjour bonjour Patrice
donc on reparlera avec vous de de avec
plaisir les chos évolu en plus les
choses évoluent Florence Mercadé bonjour
vous êtes avocate au barreau de
versaill mapha lar oui bonjour bonjour
Toujours à la pharmacie et le club de de
trappe et vous êtes allé voir vos
collègues de de montelaville ouais moi
je suis aller sur le terrain en fait je
vous Racon ça tout à l'heure raconterer
voilà combien c'est important peut-être
d'avoir des subventions qu' tenit un
club de football c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis pas venu pendant
quelques temps et vous nous avez
beaucoup manqué les
télpectateursi vous aussi vous nous avez
manqué Anton Mounard bonjour bon ça va
bien très bien alors voilà vous êtes un
peu en vacances puisque vous êtes
étudiant mais vous êtes là quand même ce
qui est très bien comme comme Sephora
Namadi bonjour Patrice ça va bien ça va
bon toujours oui toujours en vacances
aussi mais toujours en vacances et un
peu au travail aussi euh oui en stage je
dira plus en stage dans une très très
bonne maison par exemp oui c'est vrai je
la recommande et Jean-Charles la
jooignie bonjour bonjour éditeur des
édition la jooignie voilà et vous avez
travaillé non pas à Marian mais vous
avez travaillé avec Jean-François cal
pendant
longtemps peut-être avant d'aborder les
les su don dont j'ai parlé est-ce qu'il
y a des sujets dans dans l'actualité qui
vous ont frappé je crois que par exemple
la Taxi
Girl de de Lina madame Salal qui a oigé
de démissionner ça vous a interpellé ou
j'ai trouvé ça mais inimaginable
absolument cette cette dépense
somptuaire de de de taxis bien que c'est
vrai que si on les 40000 € de taxi en 10
mois si on les rapporte ça fait 4000 €
par mois ça fait par
semaine non bon ça veut dire quand même
je crois qu'il y a quelques qui ont
calculé que elle avait passé quasiment
43 jours en taxi 43 jours 43 43 nu voilà
43 jours et 43 nuits quand on est censé
diriger un truc comme Lina Chau dis mais
que que faisait-elle donc non
visiblement c'est c'est un peu
curieux moi ça appelle surtout un
commentaire au-delà de de la situation
grotesque de de de ce personnage enfin
qui s'est pas absolument pas rendu
compte 40000 € pour beaucoup de gens
c'est un salaire mirevolant déjà 40000 €
par an et 40000 € de taxi c'est une
situation quasiment prè révolutionnaire
pour plein de gens les gens vont se
direend on se moque de nous qu ça ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que il faut en même temps
peut-être se méfier un tout petit peu de
ce que la presse peut dire parce que on
s'aperçoit que on avait reproché
beaucoup de choses à Mathieu galet Radio
France il il paraît être lavé de tout
soupçon sur les dépenses de son bureau
donc le mal a été fait mais visiblement
il est quasiment accuse beauoup voil il
est quasiment pour rien dans cette
affaire tir le pan voilà alors ti le pan
on avait un petit peu parlé je suis un
peu revenu parce que lui il a été lavé
tout soupçon mais lavé de tout soupçon
par qui par la
CGT donc là c'est un peu suspect donc
c'est quand même un peu curieux c'est
comme si an nurber enfin les les nazis
mais ch égal mais bien sûr ce que je
c'est curieux de de Sauto non mais il y
a peut-être une commission d'enquête à à
la société en visiblement c'est pas lui
qui avait je préférerais que Thierry le
pan soit soit lavé tout soupçon par
quelqu'un qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
CGT voilà c'est pour ça qu' il y a
encore une petite un petit soupçon
d'innocence pour cette dirigante c'est
vraiil fa faire attention aux
informations qui nous arrivent mais
c'est vrai que sur le C Lina ça ça a
l'air ça ça a été établi par une
commission donc enfin voilàur proche
c'est c'est surtout qu'elle a communiqué
le numéro de réservation des taxiers à
son fils qui en a pleinement profité
qu'elle peut pas faire 40000 km toute
seule € tout surtout quelqu'un qui s'est
pointé après Mathieu galet parce qu'elle
succédait à Mathie
l'U patron de Radio France en disant moi
je serai ça sera une une gestion
ganéniste absolument cétait engagé
à on n pas imaginer ce que ça aurait été
s'il était arrivé sans sans prévention
sans rien dire là on serait à à 200000 €
de taxis 400000 € de nuit d'Hô est-ce
que ça ça pose je sais pas ça pose pas
problème au fond les les gens qui sont
chargés de gérer des institutions
publiques est-ce qu'il sont voilà aussi
soigneux aussi je rejoins Jean-Charles
dans ce qu'il dit euh il y a une
distance qui s'est créée entre la
société et ces gens-là je parlais
d'aristocratie et je pense que c'est de
ça dont il s'agit et ces gens ont perdu
la consence du réel et c'est extrêmement
grave ce qui est également à noter c'est
euh l'obsession de la presse a aller
lever tous ces sujets la presse je vous
le rappelle n'est pas d'utre chose que
le miroir grossissant de notre société
et cette action permanente de la presse
et de la Grand la presse grand public en
plus d'aller montrer du doigt ces
événements est significatif probablement
d'une modification sociétale importante
qui est en train de s'accélérer et tant
mieux pour tout le monde d'autres
commentaires sur ce sujets alors juste
la dernière chose c'est que elle est
elle a démissionné Lina mais elle va
retrouver un boulot tout de suite non
mais c'est ça qui est
incroyablectionn ce sont quand même des
postes et des choses o quel que soit
nature on peut parler de délit enfin de
il y a pas de sanction elle va retrouver
elle est elle est payée à la fin du mois
quand même et puis voilà elle va non
parce qu'il y a pas de délit a dépenser
trop d'argent pour les taxis enfin je
suppose c'est c'est de la mauvaise
gestion ENF c'est pas il y a pas de
sanction tout blanc en son temps était
tombé pour des CIG rappelez-vous alors
que c'était un bonhomme qui avait quand
même été la locomotive du Grand Paris
c'est assez fou que on tombe pour des
trucs pareils mais moral pour ça
ressemble voilà c'est trois affaires qui
se ressemblent un peu c'estàd que
comment des gens se coupent à un moment
des réalités de telle façon que voilà il
faut un peu n vous avez vu à quel point
ça
dégr le rôle de la presse important
làdans c'est quand même de l'argent
public c'est quand même de l'argent oui
jeux dire 40000 € c'est c'est une somme
importante comme dis JeanCharles pour
beaucoup de gens c'est au niveau de
l'État c'est pas non plus une somme
c'est pas dramatique dramatique ENF ça
pas en cause l'INA puis c'est pas de
l'argent qui est parti en Suisse il est
parti chez G7 et chez taxi bleu donc ça
faitour soutien au chauffeurs de taxi
contre le VTC pe des des des gens qui on
peut-être été déjeunés au templier voilà
donc nous acheter de la parapharmacie en
tout cas ça justifie bien la mise à pied
oui la démission démission démission
forcé la mise à pied la démission forcée
un peu un
limogage peut-être un petit mot alors là
aussi la presse raconte des choses
est-ce que ce sont des choses vraies pas
vraies vous avez l'histoire de la jupe
noir euh de cette jeune fille qui était
dans dans un lycée avec une jupe noire
et qui a était soi-disant exclu
du lycée là on apprend que c'est
peut-être plus compliqué que ça ça a
l'air ça a l'air plus compliqué parce
que c'est une une jeune fille qui
faisait visiblement beaucoup de
prosélitisme dans son lycée c'est partie
d'un groupe de jeunes
prosélites et qui vraiment de façon
entatoire serait arrivé d'abord avec un
voileurit demandé d'enlever le voile
serait revenu avec cette jupe donc
encore une fois la presse a très mal
fait son boulot c'est en en lâchant les
chiens oui c'est ridicule on vire une
jeune fille avec une jupe longue non
c'est bien plus compliqué que ça hélas
d'après Naj valouel cassem elle a pas
été renvoyé mais les enseignants ont
pris langue avec ses parents et puis
elle a été invitée à venir vêtu d'une
autre façon ce qui est pas forcément
idot donc non là-dessus pas de
commentaire je pense que le commentaire
peut-être c'est de dire que
effectivement moi je trouve que la
presse est un miroir he cont de ce que
nous sommes grossissant et donc parfois
déform déformant mon ça va non non moi
j'ai pas plus de choses à rajouter
Jean-Charles a dit a dit l'essentiel
j'aurais simplement éventuellement un
commentaire sur sur les commentaires
c'est que je suis ici et et j'entends un
peu comme un comme le feraiit les
téléspectateurs et et je me dit
effectivement en tant que téléspectateur
et aujourd'hui acteur commentateur on
nous livre des choses à la télé
simplement il y a pas le recul suffisant
donc moi je considère que la vitesse est
importante dans tous les corps de
métiers par exemple la science a besoin
d'aller très vite pour pour pour pour
trouver des des des molécules la science
a besoin d'aller très vite pour trouver
les maladies les sciences a besoin
d'aller très vite pour les diagnostique
donc la vitesse est importante on le
voit dans la bourse c'est pareil la
vitesse est importante où je veux en
venir ben je veux en venir que
probablement que c'est pas tout tout à
fait vrai pour la presse et que on nous
balance des choses très rapidement et
pour le coup c'est assez destructeur
c'est que directement il y a une espèce
de de de fix de point de fixation qui se
fait sur un événement celui-ci c'est la
la jupe tout à l'heure c'était les notes
de frais et et on se rend compte à pr à
postériori que finalement ça se dégon
plus compliqué que ça c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça c'est juste
çaeéo on a le temps de revenir
sur V vation que le commentaire se
précipite aussi et que on arrive à
commenter des faits qui ne sont pas
établis c'est juste le commentaire que
vouis faire non mais juste c'est que la
loi de mars 2004 a été parfaitement
appliquée dans dans ce cas de figure sur
interdiction de P de signe ostentatoire
religieux à l'école mais c'est couplé
avec le comportement de la personne qui
porte c'estes ces signne extérieurs donc
ce n'est pas que le signe extérieur
c'est le comportement couplé avec ce
signe extérieur et là en l'espèce ils
ont fait une parfaite application et
j'entendais qu'il y avait eu un cas
similaire il y a quelques mois dans un
autre collège personne n'en avait parlé
ça avait été traité aussi avec un renvoi
vers les vers les parents avec une
discussion une mise à plat de la
situation ça s'était réglé
tranquillement sans qu'on fasse appel à
la presse en disant tout n'importe quoi
sans aller jusqu'au fond des choses
après moi je alors je sais pas j'ai
peut-être pas suivi dès le départ
l'histoire mais le tir a dû être corrigé
dans la presse parce que tout ce que
j'ai lu au sujet de cette histoire
c'était justement l'explication que les
gens s'étaient peut-être saisis trop
vite de cette affaire parce que on les
réseaux sociaux s'enflamme ça se voit
les gens criant euh à au au côté
imbécile de la décision justement ne
pensant que il n'est question que de la
longueur de la jupe mais je peux vous
assurer que dans tous les articles que
j'ai lu était bien mentionné le fait que
justement il y avait apparemment en
cause un
comportement de provocation du
prosélitisme donc peut-être que la
presse est allé trop vite mais je crois
que derrière ça a été corrigé en tout
cas hein en tout cas oui c'est ça
c'était pas seul le seul fait de porter
une jupe comme ça qui était qui posait
problè sur ça peut aussi se régler sans
qu'il ait la PR aussi donc des
comportements comme ça il y a des
comportements délictueux il y en a des
comportement proséitiste il y en a des
des provocateurs il y en a bon à un
moment donné on n pas obligé tout le
temps en faire intéressant ça serait de
savoir comment la formation comment la
formation arrive d'ailleurs parce que ça
se passe voilà dans dans un
établissement ça pourrait être quelque
chose d'interne enfin je veux dire moi
j'ai pris on appelle la presse locale et
puis la presse locale s'en empare et
puis du coup on se dit tiens ça peut ça
peut intéressant parce que ça peut faire
du buzz ça peut créer des comment aour
on a eu tous des sanctions quand on
était au collège au lycée je dire jamais
faittic de pressep évolue vraiment parce
que un moment on rallit parce que les
jupes étaient trop courtes dans les lé
maintenant sont trop
longes
en ce moment en France on est vraiment à
fleur de peau sur ces sujets là on
rebouclera avec Estrosi mais on est
complètement justement je crois que vous
vouliez parler de de de de de Christian
Estrosi qui est le maire de Nice qui est
le candidat de l'UMP et je crois qu'il
faut le rappeler parce que c'est
peut-être pas sans rapport avec avec ses
propos à la présidence de la région
Provence Côte d'Azur et qui a parlé en
effet de 5e colonne contre l'islam enfin
l'islamislamiste qui constituait une 5e
colonne c'est une référence à la à la
deuxème guerre mondiale qui parle de
guerre euh je crois que Florence vous
avez été un peu choqué par ces par ces
propos ben j'ai été choqué parce que
clairement enfin je veux dire la ficelle
est énorme quoi on est purement dans de
la dans de la manipulation avant les
élections régionales il a en face de lui
la nièce Le Pen et il a repris
textuellement des propos qui ont été
prononcés par je sais plus son nom
emerck choprad du Front national qui
avait exactement dit la même chose il y
a quelques mois qui avait été ex
d'as Leen de sonste et il reprend
d'ailleurs chprade a demandé des droits
d'auteur un peu de façon humoristique
sur sur cette phrase là donc clairement
la ligne la ligne de pour essayer de
venir draguer entre guillemets les les
électeurs du Front ouais du vote Front
national en vue de ces élections là me
paraît quand même assez énorme et puis
on est on est typiquement dans tout ce
qui peut être
complotiste de manière assez exagérée je
pense que quand il écrit il nous dit les
5è colonne leur réseau infiltré dans nos
caves dans nos garages dans les lieux
clandestins quand même peut-être pas
exagérer qu je bah ils ont pas pignon
sur rue non mais ils ont peut-être pas
pignon sur rue mais enfin les frères
quachi ils habitaient pas dans une cave
ni dans un garage ils habitaent dans un
appartement enfin je veux dire les
choses sont différentes et là on est
complètement il me semble dans une
espèce de de truc qu'on monte en
mayonnaise uniquement dans un but
politique électoral je dis pas qu'il a
tort et que il se passe rien en France
mais enfin des attentats terroristes en
France on en a connu quand même depuis
depuis depuis 30 ans depuis 2001 on est
en guerre contre le
terrorisme ça continue ça prend d'autres
fores avec daesh je suis assez d'accord
qu'
sujet j'admets que il y a un vrai sujet
sur la problématique du terrorisme mais
est là dans des propos complètement
paranoï et volontairement manipulateur
sur un plan purement politique me choque
beaucoup c'est aussiyer des images qui
n'ont rien à voir les exctement une
espèce de
confusionnisme je comprends pas du tout
ces attaques il parle vraiment il faut
reciter ce qu'il dit il parle de de
guerre contre la civilisation
judéo-chrétienne et de 5e colonne alors
il y il y a trois éléments une guerre je
pense que tout le monde sera d'accord
que c'est une véritable guerre enfin je
veux dire les les les les gens de daesh
de Boko Haram enfin les islamistes
intégriste vraiment déclarer une guerre
le nier serait comme de nier que cette
table blanche enfin je veux dire donc la
guerre il a pas tort là où il a tort et
il rentre probablement dans le jeu de de
de nos ennemis c'est-à-dire c'est de de
de parler de d'attaque contre les
judéo-chrétiens contre le le la
civilisation judéo-chrétienne nous on n
pas à se positionner comme le font les
musulmans intégriste on n pas on n pas à
se positionner dans une guerre de
religion c'est une guerre contre
l'Occident contre la civilisation
occidentale c'est pas une guerre contre
les judé la civilisation
judéo-chrétienne c'est là où je trouve
que estrosiator après là où il est
probablement exagéré c'est de parler de
5e colonne mais en même temps vous vous
évoquez un détail qu'est-ce que ça peut
faire qu'ils habitent dans une cave ou
dans un appartement de deux pièces dans
un peu importe ces gens-là existent et
et et encore une fois mettre la
poussière sous mais non mais c'est pas
grave ils sont très peu il suffit deux
pour faire un carnage on le sait bien
donc ce n'est pas grave ces gens-là
existent 5è colonne c'est sûrement un
terme qui est pas très habile mais c'est
pas complètement faux on sait on l'a vu
encore avec le type qui voulait don le
nom m'échappe mais qui qui vient d'être
arrêté avec son complice enfin en ce
moment qui voulait attaquer des églises
on sait très bien que ces gens-là
existent et qu'il y a des sortes d' gens
dormant ou ou hélas réveiller qui ont
l'intention de commettre des des des
attentats il y a pas 7000 7000
militaires 24h 24 sur le pied de guerre
en France pour juste faire tourner les
machines de de la Défense nationale
c'est une réalité donc encore une fois
dire que évoquer ce problème le dénoncer
et l'identifier c'est faire le jeu du
Front national non faire le jeu du Front
national c'est dire que ça n'existe pas
c'est ça parce que les gens se rendent
bien compte que le terrorisme existe les
gens se rendent bien compte qu'il y a
des salopards et les gens se rendent
bien compte que cette guerre existe et
dire que ça n'existe pas et qu''estri
est un abruti c'est réducteur et c'est
dommage j'ai pas dit que c'était un
abruti ni que quo que mais ni
que ni que je ne ni pas le fait que il y
a une guerre et qu'on a un vrai problème
par que je condamne c'est le discours la
façon dont c'est dit en utilisant des
mots qui sont pas des mots neutres 5è
colonne c'est pas neutre c'est de
reprendre des mots du Front national
pour essayer de faire de la récupération
politique je pense que c'est utiliser un
vrai problème grave comme vous le dites
vrais problème grave de politique de
sécurité sur notre territoire mais de le
de le manipuler de manière politique en
vue d'élection régional je veux dire la
ficelle elle est énorme et enfin dernier
sur judéo chrétiens les plus grandes
victimes de daesh sont des musulmans pas
forcément les on va pas rentrer dans une
on va pas rentrer dans une comptabilité
morbide parce que je veux dire ça nous
entraîn trop
loin c'est plutôt les pays musulmans il
y a le plus de dégâts qui sur ce sujet
je crois qu'il faut revenir à ce que
nous disons tout à l'heure euh les
hommes et les femmes politiques
aujourd'hui sont obligés d'être dans des
arguments caricaturaux parce que si ils
font des explications de texte chaque
fois qu'ils font une déclaration aucun
journau ne les reprend donc ils sont
hélas dans cette problématique du trop
vite trop fort et donc on est dans la
caricature permanente et les réseaux
sociaux comme le disait Sephora tout à
l'heure font le jeu de ça donc
aujourd'hui avec Twitter avec Facebook
il faut être le plus court le plus
concis possible pour qu'elle est obligé
d'être en permanence dans la caricature
ça n personne et en tout cas pas la
société si on veut l'apaiser ça exacerbe
tous les sentiments ça radicalise les
comportements et c'est d'une extrême
dangerosité en même temps est-ce que
nous pouvons permettre là demain matin
aux hommes politiques de faire de
l'explication de texte sur les grandes
idées qu'ils doivent développer hélas
nonrait du temps et puis pardon pardon
arrêtons avec cette 5e colonne de dire
que la 5e colonne serait un vocabulaire
et un mot du du Front national la 5è
colonne existait bien avant le Front
National et et la majorité des gens des
jeunes ignorent totalement ce que peut
être la 5è colonne ENF dire ce n'est pas
le vocabulaire du Front national la 5e
colonne non que le Front national ce
soit un moment accapar on VO bien ce que
ça veut dire c'està dire que c'est des
gens qui sont qui sont parmi nous mais
sont indétectable c'est déconnecté du
Front national c'est un vocabulaire de
la non c'est juste que Jean-Charles nous
dit tout simplement nous sommes en
guerre et c'est une évidence nous sommes
en guerre je crois que personne ne peut
dire le contraire on n'est pas en guerre
si ce n'est la guerre des mots peut-être
la guerre des mots comme cela
effectivement il y a des mots qui sont
puissamment évoqué la 5e colonne dont on
fait état effectivement il y a
probablement sur le territoire français
des gens qui sont
ennemi d'un mode de vie
ennemi probablement même de la
République ennemi peut-être de de ce
qu'on peut on on pourrait nous évoquer
même de la liberté la liberté de
conscience la liberté de prise de Paro
et ennemis de l'intérieur de là évoquer
la 5e colonne et les mots de guerre
alors si on est en guerre au moins une
chose que vous m'accorderait aussi c'est
que quand on fait la guerre on fait de
la stratégie avant même d'aller
combattre comme on l' tous sur le
terrain à savoir que on envoie des
fantasin sans avoir de stratégie alors
je dirais que il y a une stratégie
probablement de de daesh ou une
stratégie de bokoaram ou une stratégie
de tout ces gens-là c'est que la seule
et unique stratégie qu'il ai en tête
c'est celle de faire du bruit de faire
du buzz les mot on un sens quand on
décapite en direct des gens et que ça
passe au journal de 20h ça fait du bruit
ça fait du buzz et il recherche qu'une
chose ils sont très très très peu
nombreux ils sont loin et ils sont peu
nombreux la stratégie ça serait quoi ça
serait qu'il soit beaucoup plus nombreux
et beaucoup plus proches alors on va
chercher les réservistes on va chercher
les réservistes en provoquant deux camps
qui peuvent se radicalisé on a des
minoritaires d'un côté une très grande
majorité qui vit pacifiquement les
choses et non pas en guerre qui sont en
en conflit en tous les cas sur cette
manière de penser cette façon de faire
sauf que à dire des choses comme ça
jeanch nous sommes en guerre
radicalisons-nous prenons les armes
mettons l'armée sur le alors là pour le
coup mais l'armée est
est mais elle fait des opérations de
police pour moment elle est sous la tour
elle va probablement rentrer dans les
quaines pour moi c'est pas son boularm
Afrique mais pour moi c'est pas ah oui
est sur le territoire
afriainer guerre contre en guerre contre
alors on est on est en guerre
ance mais on parle pas de la France on
parle on parle du monde entier le France
comend il est porteparole de l'état
major dit c'est une guerre contre la
civilisation judéochrétienne moi je dis
c'est une guerre contre l'Occident
contre la civilisation ocdentale voilà
moi j'aimerais qu'on prouve que c'est
pas une
guerre qu'on démitifie et qu'on dégonfle
un peu le propos parce que des propos
comme la guerre et la surenchère des
mots ouais ça va probablement c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être ce qu' cherche
eux
oui sur sur les propos d'Estrosi moi je
trouve que c'est vraiment du fantasme
qu'on vend pour récupérer des électeurs
du Front national la base militante du
fronttion vous app du fantasme parce
qu'il y a une réalité quand même oui
enfin c'est 5e colonne c'est des termes
complotistes enfin c'est des c'est des
choses qui qui existent dans les esprits
de certains mais voilà moi je trouve que
c'est voilà c'est vraiment c'est c'est
ça c'est des propos dégueulasse qui
participe à une ambiance dégueulasse euh
j'ai même pas envie de pousser le
commentaire plus quoi c'est V bah je je
partage je partage assez les les avis de
de Jean lui et Florence dans le sens où
euh jeanchles non pas Jean-Charles non
enfin pas totalement ce que je veux dire
c'est que effectivement il y a une
guerre à mener contre daesh et Boko
Haram qu même il y a une guerre à mener
contre daesh et bam on en parlait la
dernière fois on parlait justement de
l'inertie de la communauté
internationale par rapport on avait
parlé de l'anniversaire et tout donc il
y a vraiment quelque chose qui doit être
mené à ce niveau-là maintenant en France
qu'est-ce qu' cherche il cherche à faire
peur il cherche à inquiéter les esprits
tous les gens qui n'ont pas la capacité
d'analyser ce qui se passe réellement
tous les gens qui comme Florence les G
sont pas inqui mais tous les gens qui
comme Florence ne se rendent pas compte
que les principales victimes de daesh
sont des musulmans se sentent tout de
suite inquiétés l'étranger fait peur ce
qui est différent fait peur est rendu
compte j'ai j'ai dit comme Florence ne
s'en rend pas compte non j'ai dit comme
flence oui
pardonon comprenne bien pard voilà c'est
pour qu' comprenne bien c'est les gens
qui n'arrivent pas à décrypter comme
Florence se sent très inquiet et
estroszi il il part dans cette voilà il
part dans cette brèche qui est facile et
c'est c'est une façon de de répandre une
terreur et puis comme dit de de
manipuler les prochaines élections alors
je vous cite François Baou qui qui dit
voilà ce sont des propos extrêmement
dangereux pour le pays parce que au fond
il y a une ligne de fracture entre ceux
qui veulent construire leur prospérité
électorale sur la culture de
l'affrontement et ceux qui veulent
construire l'avenir du pays sur une
unité est-ce que c'est toujours amusant
les paroles de
Pérou non mais c'est vrai moi je trouve
qu'il a il a
raison est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut
est-ce qu'il faut aller sur
l'affrontement a un mec qui veut bien ou
al c'est
bien
de on le cherchait on le cherchait non
mais j'ai voté beou ça fait un certain
temps mais c'est bien il faut il faut
lui téléphoner non non non euh on lui
téléphonera pas tout de suite mais mais
c'est un homme en tout cas c'est non cel
non non mais cela dit ce qu'il dit c'est
juste enfin c'est on peut avoir ou la
culture de l'affrontement ou la culture
de l'unité et c'est vrai que les propos
d'astroside ne vont pas avec la culture
de l'unité oui mais la culture de
l'unité on sait ce que ça donne c'est
c'est c'est c'est la culture de c'est la
culture de Munich c'est c'est c'est la
culture mais si c'est la culture où on
accepte tout on n'est jamais là à
reconnaître quoi que ce soit et puis
c'est seulement quand le drame est
arrivé qu'on oui tiens on aurait dû être
plus vigilant ah oui bah finalement non
c'est ça mais mais c'est vrai que c'est
c'est pratique de rassurer d'endormir
les gens mais non mais rien n'est grave
mais c'est pas grave on est tousag pas
de rassur drtis de dire les gens n les
gens n'ont pas peur et dès que quelqu'un
à la moindre crainte on dit oh là là
c'est le Front national on peut avoir
peur sans être du Front national on peut
être on peut avoir peur être de gauche
on peut être effrayé par les terroristes
sans être d'extrême droite et et voilà
et dès que quelqu'un a pris conscience
de ça on dit ou là là c'est Satan C
trucs il veut mettre le pays à feu à 100
non pas du tout pas du tout reconnaissez
que les gens ne sont peut-être pas aussi
intelligents que vous ils peuvent avoir
peur ils ont pas toutes les mais ils ont
de de par ces discours de par ces
discours qui les inquiète qui les
inquiète et qui les manipule et qui leur
livre sur un plateau le fait qu'on crée
un ennemi et cet ennemi sont les
islamistes et en France il que des
Islam
VO voirour de l'église de SC
là où les les attentats étaient
programmés si ce que pensent les gens
allez voir s'ils ont pas peur s'ils sont
pas terrorisés allez-y si maintenant
vous me dites non ils s'en foutent ils
sont là oh oui c'était c'est un type
isolé il est tout seul il voulait faire
un attentat oh il voulait faire sauter
l'église mais c'est pas grave on a pas
peur on va le dire autrement on va le
dire autrementch tout le monde a peur
moi le premier je pense probablement que
tu as peur aussi vous avez peur ok
simplement est-ce que le rôle d'un
politique c'est pas de trouver des
solutions au quel cas les solutions
cherchonsles ensemble plutôt que que
d'essayer de fragmenter des camps et de
faire en sorte que tout le monde ait
peur même ceux qui sont résolument
encore une fois on on est en démocratie
est les candidats sur en tête de liste
on va voter pour lui on va pas voter
pour lui il a un programme il le fait on
remet pas en cause le droit de vote ou
la démocratie simplement on cherche à
élire des gens qui ont probablement des
propositions à faire et la proposition
ultime qu'on voudrait faire quand on
gère un pays quand on gère une nation
quand on gère un groupe c'est pas
spécialement de rechercher la peur des
uns euh euh le rejet de l'autre mais
c'est au contraire de trouver des
solutions est-ce que c'est constructeur
ce qui ce qui est dit là est-ce que ça
apporte un début de solution de dire je
pense que c'est rassurant pour les gens
même les RG n'ont pas compris ça qu'
avait la 5e colonne en en gros on a un
pays je l'ai dit je on a un pays qui n'a
pas de renseignement on a P je l'ai dit
je l'ai dit au début bah le
renseignement il est très bon par
certains côtés bah tout le monde sait
quand même que c'est totalement par
hasard qu'on a arrêté le typeou bon donc
voilà les renseignements ils sont très
bons enfin ils sont pas non plus
euh on prend cet événement pour dire que
c'était du hasard simplement il y a
plein il y a plein de de fois où c'était
pas du tout le hasard mais c'était bien
des professionnels qui ont bien fait
leur métier alors on parle de celui-ci
parce que c'était le hasard mais de
façon beaucoup plus massive il y a des
affaires qui sont déjouées par des gens
dont c'est le métier et les politiques
sont là pour trouver aussi des solutions
et nous-même société civile je parle des
politiques pardon je devrais parler de
tous tous ensemble notre vigilance
commune notre envie de vivre ensemble
les politiques sont pas là pour dire
dormez tranquille il se passe rien mais
c'est pas ce qu'on demande mais c'est
pas nous les Ch
le problème jechles c'est ça que je dis
non non mais il est clair qu'il faut pas
dormir comme on a pu dormir à une
certaine époque de temps en temps faut
rester avec un œil vigilant moi le
premier mais mais de là les
jetons JeanCharles c'est de ça dont je
parle et des propos comme ceux ça va
plutôt dans le sens ça alimente les
idéologie raciste et je vois il y avait
la journée de la déportation le weekend
dernier et il y avait un un ancien
résistant un ancien combattant qui nous
qui nous expliquait clairement qu'en ce
moment il avait l'impression de revivre
ce qu'il ce qu'il avait vécu lui-même
justement à la période Hitler en disant
on sent vraiment qu'il y a une montée à
nouveau d'idéologie raciste de
xénophobie de gens qui ont peur et cette
terreur civile et sociale risque
d'amener si on narrive pas à l'endiguer
et si justement on narrête pas de
l'alimenter par ce type de discours on
va arriver exactement au même résultat
c'est ce qui se profile s oui mais la
guerre des sanction vigilance chercheur
américain appelé la guerre des
civilisations c'est aussi peut-être vers
là où vous nous poussez DA oui ils
veulent en tout les cas c'est clair
qu'ils ont une stratégie et voilà
clairement c'est clairement celle ce qui
est surtout terrifiant c'est que euh
l'ensemble des sociétés occidentales
mais je dirais même mondial attendent
toutous avec impatience l'émergence
d'une femme ou d'un homme politique
capable de les projeter dans l'avenir
pour leurs enfants pour leurs petits-
enfants à l'âge que j'ai moi tout ce que
je fais toute l'énergie que je dépense
est au profit de mes enfants et de mes
petits- enfants et j'attends avec
impatience euh un personnage femme ou
homme capable de pouvoir nous amener
ensemble vers un vrai projet d'avenir
pour le moment on est là à discuter de
choses qui sont extrêmement TER à terre
qui ne nous intéresse que aujourd'hui et
éventuellement pour demain matin mais
qu'est-ce que nous faisons pour dans 10
ans dans 20 ans rien on n'entend pas un
une femme ou un homme politique parler
de ça en Europe aujourd'hui c'est un
véritable problème quand même alors nous
allons continuer à avoir des
conversation sur l'islamisation les
propos caricaturaux des uns et des
autres mais en même temps nos enfants et
surtout moi je pense à mes petits
enfants qu'est-ce qu'on leur amène
quelle est la projection que l'on fait
pour eux de notre société de demain je
crains que pour dans 20 ans on parle
toujours d'islamisation de la société
j'en ai peur si on continue comme ça
donc je pense qu'il faut briser cela et
je préconise pour ma part le
renversement de la table la remise àu
d'un couvert et l'émergence d'une vraie
société capable de s'exprimer ce qui
n'est plus le cas je comprends pas c
c'est le terme que je comprends pas
jeanchle je crains qu'on parle de plus
en plus de l'islamisation comme si
c'était un mouvement coordonné alors
pour le coup qui reprennent les propos
un peu paranoïques mais cette
islamisation c'est quoi c'est le fait
qu'il est de plus en plus de musulmans
islamique
islamisé et qui et qui prendre
l'islamisation ou c'est c'est ça que je
vrais comprendre parce que est-ce que
est-ce que c'est la démographie dont tu
parles ou c'est le je comprends pas il y
a plus en plus d'islamisation moi je
j'en vois pas autour de moi j'ai pas dit
qu'il y a plus de plus en plus
d'islamisation j'ai dit que
la mais le souci en fait que tu
identifies par l'islamisation qu'est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est le terrorisme
est-ce que c'est le fait qu'il est juste
de plus en plus de
musulans
Just exemple j'imagine que patri cétait
le prochain sujet qu'on all
aborder l'éducation
nationale cette brillante Naj qui
propose de de de sabrer des pans entiers
de l'histoire de France pour rendre
obligatoire l'oig le l'instruction de de
certaines parties historiques et avec
une partie énorme consacrée à l'islam ça
fait partie de l'islamisation donc on a
une
ministre
l'AM peut-être qu'on va parler de
l'éducation je voudrais qu'on dise un
mot par avec vous Mustapha peut-être de
de on est un peu loin de ça mais enfin
quand même de du Front national qui
supprime pas si loin c'est pour ça que
je permettis de vous en parler
maintenant parce queou le frond national
qui supprime des subventions des clubs
de football c'est le cas à montelaville
où le National a étélu on n pas si loin
si ce n'est que moi je me suis éloigné
de cette table pour ne pas faire que des
commentaires mais je suis le reporter de
cette émission n'est-ce pas et donc je
suis allé sur le terrain mesdam
messieurs je vais donc vous raconter
envoy spéciau aujourd'hui c'est vous et
Jean-Luc on on a le report on a le
reportage je cro la cha alors on regarde
et
après
non vous êtes vous êtes allé à mon en
effet non le la municipalité Front
National a supprimé les subventions club
alors pour que les téléspectateurs
comprennent bien un club de foot est une
association de 1901 qui reçoit
essentiellement des subventions pour se
financer sur mante la jolie MT laaville
et buelet c'est un on va dire un
groupement de de club don c'est une
entente et ils ont créé donc le le Club
un club de football sur trois commune
chaque commune verse des
subventions au prorata du nombre
d'habitants pas forcément au prorata du
nombre d'adhérents c'est là que ça va se
compliquer tout à l'heure mais par
contre la municipalité de mantelaville
qui est fraîchement élu depuis donc l'an
dernier au dernier municipal a décidé
tout de suite en arrivant de baisser les
subventions au club de foot jusque là
rien de choquant après tout après tout
ils ont le droit après tout un ils ont
le droit ils ont été élus c'est la
raison pour laquelle je tout à l'heure
l'utilité du vote parce qu'à un moment
donné B on en a au moins une preuve il y
en a d'autres mais au moins çaen est une
l'utilité du vot et donc ils sont
arrivés et ils ont baissé les
subventions de 15000 € pour être précis
et puis l'année suivante ils ont baissé
la subvention de manth la Ville de 75000
€ voilà c'est comme si moi au club de
foot de trappe On Me On Me retirait 80 %
de mes subventions 100000 au total
100000 au total de subventions alors on
est sur un bassin beaucoup plus
important à Man la jolie parce que ce
sont des communes beaucoup plus
importantes que la ville de trappe
simplement ils sont aux alentours de
1000 adhérents également
quand vous faites le calcul allez 100000
€ de subvention me concernant pour 1000
adhérents ça nous amène à pour le coup à
euh 100 100 € 100 € de l'adhérent de
subvention de la municipalité vous
faites le calcul on est à moins de 50
centimes de l'heure de la pratique du
football puisque les 100 € quand vous le
ramenez à 5h par semaine à 40 semaines
par an vous êtes à 50 centimes de
l'heure de la pratique du football qui à
mon avis beaucoup moins cher que toute
pratique par ailleurs mais c'est surtout
que ces subventions avec lesquelles on
vit nous on les donne à des éducateurs
qui touchent quoi alors pourquoi c'est
indispensableil bah ça l' parce qu'il y
a 40 éducateurs autour quand vous avez
1000 adhérents alors il faut être aussi
très clair il y a il y a chez moi chez
nous il y a 800 footballeurs pratiquants
on va dire pratiquant football hein pas
il y a pas l'islamisation viens
c'est non justement on sera pas les deux
pour le coup non pour le coup non mais
faut bien en parler parce que c'est un
des reproches que fait la municipalité
frond nationale je vais venir c'est pour
ça que jeis bouclé jeai bouclé et donc
200 encadrants qui sont des bénévoles
vous avez 800 gamins qui sont encadrés
par une quarantaine de bénévoles de de
d'éducateurs c'est quoi un éducateur
c'est quelqu'un qui est sur le terrain
avec tous ses gosses toute l'année qui
touche allez 100 150 € par mois de
défraimement mais qui pluset habite la
ville c'estàd que mes nos éducateurs
sont sur les terrains toute la semaine
et ils sont dans la ville donc en gros
il participe au vivre ensemble
Jean-Charles on participe par le club de
foot avec 1000 adhérents et la majorité
donc des enfants avec des éducateurs qui
leur font passer alors j'aime pas trop
ces notions de valeur par le foot parce
qu'en réalité c'est consubstantiel tout
le monde le sait à un moment donné quand
tu dis un gamin tu sers la main d'un
d'un joueur adverse c'est vrai que c'est
une valeur enfin il y a un peu de bon
sens aussi il y a un peu d'éducation
normale il y a un peu de et donc on on
on gère un club de foot avec 50 centimes
de l'URE par gamin cet argent reste dans
dans la commune puisque ce sont des
éducateurs de la commune et ces mêmes
éducateurs sont dans la ville toute
l'année au Front national quand on
décide à mon avis de faire un coup
également parce qu'on en parle on en a
parlé sur M6 je crois de cette affaire
sur France 2 stade 2 donc stade 2 donc
les chaînes nationales s'en sont en
paril donc encore une fois on a le rôle
de la Press syque le rôle de la presse
qui pour le coup fait bien son boulot
également de mettre en avant ce genre de
chos mais j'ai le sentiment qu'il y a
également encore une fois une stratégie
il y a des stratèges effectivement chez
DAEs il y a des stratèges au Front
national il y a des stratèges dans les
partis politiques et probablement
questry fait partie des stratèges de
l'UMP et donc toutes ces stratégies
visent à un moment donné à crisper à
radicaliser et là qu'est-ce qui se passe
à m-laajolie à man-elaville c'est même
pas dit pour y être aller donc j'ai
rencontré les acteurs sur le terrain
j'ai rencontré le Président j'ai
rencontré les acteurs locaux j'ai
rencontré des gens dans les terrains il
y avait un match de foot de ce genour-là
PSG PSG manth avant le PSG Bastien et
tout le monde le dit le problème c'est
qu'on ne sait pas pourquoi parce qu'à la
limite quand tu sais pourquoi on te
retire 100 % de ta subvention bah
probablement parce qu'il y a eu je sais
pas
moiation mais clairement ils ne disent
pas et c'est pourtant ça il y a pas de
Bur et Black chez nous on participe pas
à une communauté où statistiquement il
nous représente pas al le maire Fond
national disait que le club de foot
favorisit le certains communautarism
reprenons les statistiques alors
reprenons dans ce pays les statistiques
qu'on a tant décrié de façon à ce qu'on
puisse dire il y a 30 % de beurre il y a
30 % de Black à manentel ville et pas à
Manent la jolie auquel cas les
subventions seront distribué au prorata
aux statistiques tantéc par certains
mais on en est là sauf que les choses ne
sont pas dites on nous dit pas il y a
trop de beur et trop de BL sachant que
nous on les app pas donc on contribue
pas à ce Meltin Pot qui n'est pas le
nôtre c'est simplement on considère que
il y a 250000 € de travaux qui vont être
faits sur les installations et donc il
est normal que nous récupérions de
l'argent voilà voà sauf que les
installations les 250000 € pour être
précis Patrice les 250000 € c'est
d'abord c'est une charge sur la commune
réelle et sérieuse mais par le biais des
amortissements c'est pas tout à fait le
le coût réel deuxièmement c'est
généralement des investissements sur des
10 15 20 ans et troisièmement surtout 50
% du budget est pris en charge par la
casquie locale la comité d'aglomération
locale 50 % qui pris en charge et enfin
le reste est pris en charge par les
autres communes en gros pour le Front
national pour la ville de pour la ville
de Man ça représente pour le coup pas
grandchose c'est juste pouvoir dire on a
un argument pour faire des économies
sans dire les choses nommer les choses
et c'est ça qui m'inquiète moi quand je
dis qu'on fout les jetons aux gens mais
on dit pas les choses nom les choses on
est dans la guerre des mots alors pour
le coup nomons les choses il y a trop de
beur et trop de BL subventionné par une
ville beaucoup plus blanche et au quelqu
on particip à ça sauf que sauf que tout
le monde vit sur le même bassin et qu'on
a besoin de vivre en commun auquel cas
est-ce qu'on veut vivre ensemble les
politiques veulent décider de vivre
ensemble au contraire veulent fragmenter
et là le Front national participe de ça
à 50 centimes de l'heure que tu as
beaucoup d'enfants qui font des
pratiques et des loisirs éducatives pour
le coup réelle et sérieuse à 50
centimesll vous prêchez unconvaincu
maintenant que que les gens du Front
national sont un peu bas de plafond
c'est pas une découverte qu'on fait là
aujourd'hui un constat que je fais c'est
un
constatantémoign all je all repor parce
que j'étais crédible on m'a dit tiens tu
passeras tes couleurs local
pas
c'est stupide et puis c'est tout voilà
ça je relate je rel je suis pas dans les
commentaires un peu
mon par cont par contre sur le plan
national parce qu'il y a quand même une
stratégie nationale alors moi j'ai une
chose à dire aux gens qui nous écoutent
et qui pourraient être tentés par le
vote Front national souvent il parle de
repli pour le coup sur les frontières on
sera d'accord pour la sortie de l'euro
probablement même allez peut-être pas de
l'Europe mais au moins d'un euro de
l'euro de l'euro euh il y a un maître
mot au Front national c'est la
préservation de l'emploi c'est jusque là
ce sont des emplois non
délocalisables et tous ces emplois vont
partir parce que le club de Man ne
pourra plus payer ces deux salariés donc
ces deux salariés pour le coup en gros
c'est 30000 € par personne quand charge
charge pas trop comprise donc cas il y a
déjà de deux salariés en moins et des
éducateurs qui seront plus payés mais
arrêtez de toute façon de par
on pas dans les travx du patronat qui
délocalise multiplié par le nombre de
communes sur cette
France c'est énervant d'entendre des des
trucs en disant le Front national se
positionne pour la sortie de l'Europe de
sortie de l'E le frond national est
grotes sur sur toute cette partie là
gr Mo je suis plus dans le
commentaire de
National une stratégie nationale voilà
un exemple sauf qu'un exemple comme
celui-ci multiplié par des centaines
d'exemples comme celui-ci je suis pas
certain que ça soit solution au niveau
du département justement de la
communauté d'agomationou il sont engagés
à payer une partie des frais donc il est
souverain dans sa commune si je peux me
permettre l'expression auquel cas ouais
il y aura des subventions spéciales dans
le cas de la politique de la ville il y
aura des subventions qui seront allouées
par la comité d'agglomération locale
donc les travaux vont se faire les
subventions vont probablement arriver
par ailleurs mais je tiens à préciser
quand même à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
encore une fois c'est vrai dans toutes
les communes Jean-Charles la casquie a
voté il y a 3 jours la diminution je
crois pas me tromper en disant de 30 %
des subventions aux associations
sportives et culturelles c'est énorme ah
mais c'est vrai pour toute la France
parce que les allocations allouées par
le gouvernement au comité au collectif
et local sont réduit donc tout le monde
fait l'effort mais là c'est pas un
effort c'est un prétexte toute la
différence d'accord euh autre sujet je
voudrais qu'on revienne puisquon en
avait parlé la dernière fois que
concerne le tourisme on parler de
l'éducation peut-être après peut-être de
l'immigration aussi je sais pas si on
aura le temps parce qu'il nous reste à
peine une dizaine de minutes euh je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur l'affaire
booking.com contre les hôelers les
restaurateurs ou plutôt les
restaurateurs et les hers contreingom
sens dans le fait où les la dernière
fois vous avvez dit bon il y a pas
grandchose non mais là les efforts ont
été faits mais en réalité là aussi on a
un peu raccourci ce qui est émanit des
discussions entre les responsables de
booking et l'État français c'est que
jusqu'à présent les contrat de booking à
l'égard des aôteliers était extrêmement
contraignant h et interdisait à un
aôtelier de pouvoir vendre ses chambres
en dessous des prix affichés par booking
sur Internet booking a accepté du bout
des lèvres que l'aôutelier puisse
reprendre la maîtrise de ses prix et de
ses promotions à condition que ça ne
soit pas sur internet mais par des biais
de promotion particulière avec quand
même un certain nombre de contraintte
qui fait que il va falloir quand même
que l'ôtelier fasse très très attention
à la façon dont il va pouvoir afficher
ses prix parce que booking a donné un
signe qui paraît être un bon signe pour
que l'hôtelier reprennne sa liberté de
proposition de tarif en réalité c'est
pas tout à fait ça donc booking reste
encore le leader sur la les prestations
d'hôteli dans un grand nombre de cas en
tous les cas sur le territoire français
et booking reste toujours le leader
mondial des réservations hôtelières je
vais vous donner les chiffres l'autre
jour c'est faramineux et ça fait de
booking aujourd'hui la plus grande usine
à cash du monde en oubliant bien entendu
de payer les taxes qui leur reviennent
théoriquement à l'état français donc le
scandale continue mais allez il y a un
petit point d'amélioration ceéend dit
donc nous avons mis le pied dans la
porte et je pense que il va pas se
passer TR ou 4 ans avant que les choses
ne soient réellement transformées enfin
enfin le pouvoir politique et les
administrations ont pris conscience de
la dangerosité extrême des sites
internet pour la commercialisation de
produits pas seulement hôtelier c'est
valable pour la restauration c'est
valable pour pour les véhiculesà pour
plein plein de choses je vais pas
m'étaler sur le sujet c'est un peu
compliqué mais en même temps on a été
dans une espèce de foir d'en poigne où
nous étions réellement victime d'un
système qui nous dépassait et en face
duquel d'ailleurs les pouvoirs publics
n'ont rien vu venir nous sommes en train
de réagir trop lentement d'ailleurs à
mon mais vous réagissez il me semble que
dans la décision de l'Autorité de la
concurrence il y a aussi un autre point
où booking ne peut plus indiquer enfin
vous avez repris la main sur le nombre
de chambres que vous pouvez laissé pour
booking en vente et que booking ne peut
plus indiquer que l'hôtel est plein il
doit dire que sur ce
siteou dans la théorie là c'est dans la
théor être obligé de laoui c'estd si
vous allez sur Booking par exemple vous
voyez que l'El est plein Est téléphoné
il y a peut-être des chambres quand même
ce n'est pas un réflex malheureusement
il se trouve et ça c'est très important
à signaler que euh le le citoyen moyen
finalement est quand même toujours
intéressé de pouvoir payer moins cher
une qui vaut un certain prix donc de
toute façon le citoyen moyen fait
toujours le jeu de booking et et des
autres sites on parle de booking parce
que c'est le nom qui revient mais ils
sont très nombreux sur le sujet et donc
il faudra aussi et Jean-Charles en parle
souvent d'ailleurs que nous refassions
que nous remodélisions la culture
d'accès dans nos modes de consommation
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de
continuer de casser l'économie en
voulant toujours du moins cher du moins
cher et ça ne tient pas la route nous
allons en mourir si nous ne faisons pas
attention bah oui mais c'est aux
hôteliers aux restaurateurs un peu de se
bouger aussi à leur fédération de de
nous somes là pour ça mais je suis je
suis dans ces acteurs là ouendre la M je
réenfourche mon vieux cheval de bataille
c'est quand même aussi à tout le monde
de prendre cons
on dans une chamb il y a une femme de
ménage qui a fait le ménage il y a un
type à la réception il y a un concierge
un patron d'hôtel un restaurant ça on
peut pas avoir tout gratuit c'est comme
Sephora qui fut au test de l'air je veux
dire test de l' dans un avion quand on
accepte de voyager pour aller en Suède
pour 10 € on se doute bien qu'on a mis
je pas loyer des mots grossiers mais
enfin je veux dire on a tout le
monde l'est le pilote le Stewart le le
Comand tout le monde parce que à 10 €
c'est pas possible donc arrêtons cette
culture du pas cher c'est bien non pas
cher c'est bien quand on est étudiant
qu'on a pas de rond quand on a des rond
il faut accepter de payer les choses à
leur juste valeur il faut il faut les
dire et aujourd'hui malheureusement
notre mode de communication est en
caricatural sur tous les sujets à un
moment donné il va bien falloir faire un
peu d'explication de texte celle que
vient de nous faire mustaapha est
brillante mais vous avez vu un petit peu
longue parce que c'est comme ça parce
que quand on veut expliquer les choses
ça prend du temps et en même temps on
sait bien qu'on décoche très V quoi donc
on est obligé à la fois de d'être très
court dans ce que nous avons à dire sur
nos arguments et et d'être compris en
face là nous avons un vrai problème
culturel qui s'est terriblement dégradé
ces dernières années il va falloir que
nous rattrapions le temps perdu oui par
rapport justement la question des prix
moi je pense à l'alimentation quand on
on on voit ce ce qui est vendu dans les
supermarché c'est c'est affligeant voit
on regarde la composition les
ingrédients
euh c'est c'est des quantités de
matières qui sont qui sont grossissantes
et qui ont aucun aucune qualité
nutritive qui sont ajouté de façon à
faire croire qu'on achète plus mais en
fait on achète rien de plus que juste ce
couper moi je pense qu'il faut
effectivement faire attention et acheter
le au prix réel c'està-dire
qu'aujourd'hui la viande par exemple un
poulet ça coûte pas 5 € dans un
supermarché ça coûte 20 ou 30 € le kilo
si on l'élève correctement si on le
nourrit bien si on le gonfle pas aux
hormones voilà et donc il faut aussi
réfléchir à notre notre mode de vie un
mode d'alimentation il faut il faut
revoir tout ça et quand on est étudiant
moi je pense qu'on peut aussi manger de
façon qualitative mais par contre il
faut il faut faire plus soi-même
c'est-à-dire il faut préparer à manger
soi-même il faut aller voir peut-être
les producteurs directement en
organisant des circuits courts enfin il
faut trouver des astuces de façon à
réduire les coups euh mais on peut quand
mê AR y arver AR juste une remarque
juste que tout le monde veut accéder à
tout moi j'ai pas eu le poulet tous les
jours l'alimentation quand j'étais jeune
c'était très restreint mais aujourd'hui
on peut accéder à une bouffe à peu près
plus plus important tout le monde tout
le monde veut voyager tout le monde veut
des loisirs tout le monde veut est-ce
qui à peu près logique vous en
conviendrez tous
laart de ça d'ailleurs si tout le monde
voulait des livres exactement ce serait
bien malement n'oublion pas qu'il y a
des gens qui on pas les moyens non plus
mais qui ont quand même envie d'accéder
à tout et il y a des gens qui leur
offrent sauf que il leur offrent à des
conditions que vous connaissez ça
s'appelleffet de masse après au-delà de
ça je pense qu'au final c'est toujours
pour tout la même politique politique de
l'unité ou politique de l'affrontement
payer plus cher moi-même j'y vois aucun
inconvénient à partir du moment où le
prix est honnête le prix est juste si le
prestataire vient s'enrichir sur le dos
du consommateur parce qu'il se fait une
marge énorme en proposant une prestation
qui ne mérite pas le cout là je dis non
c'est toujours pareil c'est une question
d'état d'esprit c'est une question c'est
une question de philosophie c'est une
question d'honnêteté d' inéité une
question de valeur des valeurs que nous
n'avons plus parce que on fait prévaloir
l'individualisme sur le fait justement
de faire ensemble donc payz plus oui si
c'est réellement justifié parce que il y
a bon nombre il y a bon nombre de
restaurants par exemple on peut payer
quelque chose très cher ça n'a pas de
goût ça n'est pas bon pourquoi parce que
le restaurateur parce que oui mais il y
en a beaucoup des comme ça parce que le
restaurateur cherche à se faire la marge
la plus grande possible ou c'est valable
pour tout c'est pour les prestatairesel
c'est valable pour tout juste faire
attention à de Marg énorme qui est quand
même un peu un truc
totalement non mais des gens qui se font
des marges énormes en France ça se
trouve faut une lampe de poche he moi
j'invite à venir sur le parking de métro
métro qui est le premier distributeur en
France pour les restaurateurs et pour
l'ensemble des magasins alimentaires
mais surtout pour les restaurateurs vous
allez voir que sur le parking métro il y
a pas de grosses voitures hein c'est des
gens qui ont des voitures modestes et
contrairement à à ce qu'on peut imaginer
ou à aux aidés reçu depuis déjà très
longtemps le restaurateur ne gagne pas
beaucoup d'argent comparé au travail
qu'il doit fournir et au risque qu'il
prend chaque jour alors maintenant
qu'effectivement dans un certain nombre
de grands groupes qui sont aujourd'hui
la propriété de groupes financier
d'ailleurs ils cherchent à essayer de
remettre des marges en place bon soit
mais en même temps croyez bien que
aujourd'hui les restaurateurs ne
cherchent pas à tremper leur monde ils
gagnent mal leur vie et pas que
d'ailleurs parce que dans l'ensemble des
boutiques dit de produits alimentaires
ils gagnent mal leur vie aussi et et là
ce que souignait Antonin à propos de la
malbouffe c'est la conséquence d'un
ensemble de de de de décisions que nous
avons pris depuis une trentaine d'années
qui ne vont pas bien enfin moi je dirais
une chose aujourd'hui un un cuisinier
coûte à une entreprise grosso modo 36000
€ par an il faut savoir que la moitié de
cette somme lui est pris par la
collectivité publique il tous que 18000
d'accord donc là aussi il y a un vrai
problème donc je pense qu'il va falloir
que nous abordions le sujet et là on
peut pas l'abord de façon caricaturale
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le coût du
travail il est ce qu'il est mais que les
salaires donnés à nos collaboratrices et
collaborateurs sont bien trop faibles
bien sûr voilà uega à ce que ça coûte en
réalité donc il va falloir qu'on
rééquilibre tout ça on va pas le faire
maintenant mais je crois que ça fait
partie des vrais débats sur lesqueles
nous aurons à discuter pour projeter nos
enfants et nos petits- enfants dans
l'avenir il va falloir augmenter les
prix
non il va falloir augmenter les salaires
nets salair salair non pas spécialement
ba aujourd'hui 36000 € pour un salarié
de base ne me paraî pas être une folie
c'est intégré dans nos prix par contre
que la moitié de cela pris par la
collectivité publique non mais c'est pas
pris par la on dirait que c'est pris
dans à fond perdu ça va demain pas
maladie dramatiqueenvoie tous les jours
des gens qui ont pas d'argent qui se
retrouvent qui touchent 200 € par mois
ou 5 par mois demain ils ont la même
maladie que toi qui est une maladie
incurable maladie violente qui nécessite
des soins à pratiquement 10000 € par
jour la société et là faut pas penser
qu'on les enlève et qu'on les mène à
fond perdu je g j'ai des femmes de
ménage qui me disent c'est
impressionnant ce que ce que je coûte à
la société on m'a mis des grains d'or
dans la tête on m'a mis des des on a
fait des examens qui coûte une fortune
j'en reviens pas de ce qu'on fait pour
moi ouais ben on le fait pour toi parce
que c'est mérité et parce que c'est la
collectivité et c'est
G on peutut-être discuter de la manière
gér mais j'ai vraiment le sentiment
maintenant on est en train de faire
attention aux notes de frais des uns et
des autres on est en train de faire en
sorte que les gaspillages ne soient pas
ce qu' étaient ça BSE maintenant on n
est pas encore mais ça BSE dans ce sensl
mais de là à dire allez on augmente les
salaires on baisse les charges et pour
le coup tout va bien ouais c'est justeen
face il y a besoin supporter ai alors on
peut débattre mais débattons du tout ça
contraire tout bien sûr on lesatt du
tout non il voulez pas dire qu'il faut
enlever toutes les charges
person mais que peut-être 50 % c'est
beaucoup il nous reste il nous reste à
peine 2 minutes même pas donc et oui
donc je pense qu'on va traer le sujet
sur l'éducation ou alors en un mot mais
c'est compliqué en un mot hein est-ce
que vous avez voilà le le massacre des
innocents c'est le titre de de Mariane
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
va enfin que c'est le massacre des
innocents au collège commencé il y a 40
ans là on est à l'apogé continue comme
ça on fera que des ignorants une société
vide sans avenir sans perspective sans
rien il faut arrêter ça et qui pourrait
être terrorisé par les discours des
évidemment évidemment parce que parce
que unculte parce que nous connaissons
pas les choses par que nons pas la
capacité de les comprendre c'est
terrifiant même temps
alors qui était interviewé sur RTL
disait mais attendez tout ça c'est des
fantasmes c'est pas du tout ça la
réforme du collège on essaie de donner
au plus grand nombre ce que ne pouvait
avoir qu'un certain nombre de de de de
de collégien qui étaient plutôt
c'estàdire de Lang apprendre de langu
c'està-dire apprendre le latin et cetera
on veut le répondre donner à tout le
monde c'est assez faramineux ce que ce
que dire cette ministre c'estàd que
avant on se disait on a un un socle de
savoir qui est intéressant on va faire
en sorte que les gens puissent y accéder
et là elle elle a inversé le problème
elle dit bah de toute façon on va
baisser le socle de savoir et on va le
délivrer à tout le monde
c'est elle n rien mais c'est c'est c'est
le ement par le bas mais par le médiocre
en un scandale absolu et c'est pouss
pouss les enfants des
élites
prependant que la langue étrangère é
avancé d'un an on apprend
plutôt 5 la fin des langues européennes
la fin du grec la fin
la je serai là pour mi opposer quand ça
passera j'ai fait
allemand je sais combien ça compé pour
ma scolarité au détail près que c'est
pas passé c'est en
discussion ha conseil le Haut Conseil de
des programmes a mis ça en débat et en
discussion conseil des programmes il est
il est très très préoccupé parce que il
redéfinit par exemple que la natation
c'est de mouvement aquatique dans un
milieu
vertical c'est le déplacement avec un
ballon rond de façon un référentiel
bondiss et plonger c'est traverser l'eau
en équilibre horizontal par immersioné
de la tête
la même chose c'est fini mêm gens c'est
fini c'est fini aujourd'hui on se
retrouve peut-être dans 3 semaines alors
on va faire un petit break parce qu'il y
a des ponts au mois de mai donc on se
retrouvera dans 3 semaines merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette
émission